he may not yet have been proven innocent
but brazil's former president louisiana
lula da silva
is no longer a felon and he's back on
the political scene
with an eye on next year's presidential
elections
i know that i was victim of the biggest
legal lie in the 500 years of history
i know my wife died due to the high
pressure and the stroke came faster
i was forbidden to even see my brother
inside a coffin
lula's speech on wednesday was the first
since a supreme court judge
overturned the corruption convictions
which put him behind bars
for 18 months and stripped him of his
political rights
banned from the 2018 elections the
leader of brazil's left-wing workers
party
is now seen as a political threat to
president
bolsonaro he says it's too soon to talk
about next year's presidential race
but he spoke like a candidate lula is
already a very popular leader
lulu presents himself as a moderate
leader
that this time and i think that the
first speech
that he gave this wednesday was an
attempt to show that himself
is a moderate it can
put together different groups different
sectors of the brazilian society and so
i think that he's a problem a real
problem for bolsonaro and for
bolsonaro's attempt
to be re-elected lula blasted bolsonaro
for
downplaying the kovit 19 pandemic which
has already claimed the lives
of almost 270 000 brazilians
the second largest death toll after the
united states
we have a president who says covet-19 is
a small flu
who says that only cowards fear the
virus and that he does not because he's
an athlete
this is not the way a president should
act in a civilized world
bolsonaro points out that lula is still
not off the legal hook
the decision to throw out the corruption
charges
was based on a technicality the supreme
court judge
said brazil's former president had been
tried by a court
in the southern city of kurichiba that
had no jurisdiction over his case
he may still be retried in the capital
brasilia
there are many legal twists and turns in
this case
the supreme court still has to decide
whether the judge who convicted lula
was impartial or had his own political
agenda
and colluded with the prosecution
meanwhile lula has started negotiating
an alliance with other left-wing parties
and even conservative politicians
who are not happy with president jair
bolsonaro
monica yanaki of al-jazeera rio de
janeiro